it's a wide range of propaganda material
that we see on north korean tv if we
were to talk about specifically about
leadership propaganda
it would fall into three categories
generally news reports films or
documentaries about kim jong-un or his
predecessor kim il-sung and kim jong-il
the programming
is
all towards one message of solidifying
the leadership of the kim regime there
isn't much choice so you have state tv
and
that's it
you don't get a lot of netflix in north
korea
right not much binging so let's talk
about its coverage of the recent missile
launch on march 24th that used feature
film style editing what do we see
what's unusual about this one john
north korea put together this very
stylized video people were talking about
elements of top gun
bollywood type of edits i think that
this was done to compensate or to dispel
rumors of what went on and show a
success rachel what what did you take
away from that video what did you see in
that
in the past what we used to see is
basically news reports on
kim
and the way those would be presented um
is that an announcer would be seated in
a new studio um reading the news report
um for about maybe 20 to 30 seconds
to maybe about a minute and then it cuts
into
the photos or video that north korea tv
wants to show north korea's latest icbm
test coverage was significant north
korea had never put together a program
like that especially regarding a kim
leader i mean that was
so progressive so on north korean so
looking back over the past several years
what are some of the noticeable changes
in its programming and broadcast style
just in general
a few years ago i think the quality of
the broadcasting went up into a higher
definition and with that came better
sets better studios use of computer
graphics and other things as well like
putting reporters in the field to report
on typhoons you have these elements that
are coming in from abroad and making
this very stayed static broadcast of
news much more dynamic than it has been
john i agree with everything you said um
we're talking about changes as small as
bringing in a whole new generation of
announcers to bigger changes like
showing more video in the international
um segment in the newscast
so going forward then will we see more
of this this image-conscious version of
kim and an emphasis on high-quality
production
i think we will continue to see north
korean propaganda strategy in general um
evolving in terms of whether we will see
another
movie type program on kim jong-un's
public activity i'm not sure i think we
might we may not it depends i think also
on the feedback from the leadership
circle regarding the the latest icbm
test coverage
as rachel said getting the message and
the approval through the leadership
circle is difficult then you have a lot
of very old people in north korea's
upper echelon it's it's inevitable for
it to evolve but again there's only
limits to how far it can go and north
korea is also very conscious as to what
a release to the outside world
[Music]
you